great so I'm very excited to be here
this is a project I've been working on
for a while uh mostly focusing on the
organizational side of it how do you
design organizations and roles
especially when people are getting
scrutinized through social media but
given this audience would love to know
your thoughts on implications for This
research for technology design for
social media design too so I have like
designed the talk for around like 40
minutes but I would love anytime you
have any questions suggestions please
interrupt me so getting more feedback is
important so with that said let me start
uh so the focus of this talk is going to
be on uh when people use social media to
scrutinize Frontline workers Frontline
professionals what kind of impact does
it have so that's sort of the broader
Focus so let me kind of give some
examples before I relevant to the
specific study
so we all know that social media have
been used to scrutinized individuals
organizations
workers right on there like uh what one
would consider as bad practices uh
oftentimes and it had had some impact a
lot of the conversation going on today
on role of social media largely focuses
on Free Speech right could anybody use
social media for all kinds of things or
should there be some form of governance
and censorship and people talk about
things such as cancel culture right some
argue that you know that's not good
cancel culture actually inhibits Free
Speech others say there's nothing called
cancel culture cancel culture is just
accountability culture people who are
not held accountable for a long time now
you have a new tool to keep them
accountable right so that's like whole
conversation going on in the popular
press I'm not going to really talk about
that or deal with that in the main
portion of the talk to towards the end I
would but my focus is mainly on people
using social media clients general
public using social media to scrutinize
criticize Frontline workers who they
interact with so they have some problems
with an interaction they had with the
front line worker think of a call center
employee or think of someone you met at
an airline chicken counter right so they
they now can take video of them or
criticize them post them on social media
so what happens in those circumstances
so that's going to be broadly my focus
so why Frontline professionals because
oftentimes they are the ones who
interact with the customers with the
general public they act almost as
interface right they're representatives
of an organization but they interface
with outside world and they also do
important internal coordination right if
someone complains if I as a client
complains that your service is not good
it's typically these Frontline workers
who kind of assign the category of that
of that incident and perform some
coordination internally right
more broadly but because they act as
this interface
paradoxically they're also typically the
targets of social media scrutiny if
someone is unhappy uh maybe some broader
organizational policies that lets them
say certain things but it is that
particular individual that Frontline
worker who gets called out who gets
scrutinized right so that's the
phenomena I'm going to talk about
and let me kind of give what do we know
from current research on the impact of
social media is it a good thing does it
sort of improve processes improve
accountability or does it produce
different outcomes and the results have
been mixed actually we don't have a good
idea on is it good is it bad does it
produce better organizational policies
practices or does it doesn't matter
right so I'll give a couple of examples
that shows that social media scrutiny
could have a positive impact right you
might remember this United Airlines
incident where uh passenger got
forcefully pulled out because the flight
was overbooked right and that particular
video became really popular a lot of
people were you know complaining about
United so they actually took some
positive changes re-changed their or
booking policy they compensated the
person but also many other changes that
at least in principle makes the life of
the customers easy right another example
is more recent one on me too in
Hollywood right so there have been like
some empirical studies the documents
that
after the incident became really a lot
of people complained about Harvey
Weinstein uh the producers who used to
be associated with Harvey Weinstein uh
they tended to hire more female writers
they wanted to increase representation
of women in the industry so it had
produced some good outcomes right so
this is on the one hand social media
scrutiny could have could improve
accountability could produce good
outcomes on the other hand more recent
work including my own ongoing research
so just there are certain other
conditions social media scrutiny could
worsen accountability could actually
make things worse inside an organization
so this is a study on
triage nurses during the covid-19
pandemic
so when people go to the ER in a
hospital and if they're not unhappy the
triage says you're saying it doesn't
look like a serious emergency I could
assign you a certain priority level they
get very worked out they take a video of
that person
share it on social media and in turn
what happened was those Frontline
workers the triage nurses became very
risk-averse became very self-productive
because the organization was not like
you know protecting them so they would
categorize many incidents even very low
priority medical issues as you know
emergencies which in turn crowded the
whole ER system right so this these sort
of studies suggest that there could be
something else going on too social media
excluded you could actually make
Frontline workers very risk covers could
in turn you know impact accountability
in negative ways so this is what like we
know so I'm trying to figure out okay is
there a way to systematically understand
it what does underlying mechanisms that
goes on that actually improves this is
worse since accountability so that's the
focus let me give some definitions what
do I mean by accountability right how
members of a professional group think of
nurses uh how do they monitor evaluate
and enact some changes in response to
the demands of various stakeholder
groups right these could be clients this
could be the public but this could also
be other audiences like regulators right
and there is a secret now increased
demand for accountability as one of the
most popular terms used in Congressional
reports about transparency is the word
accountability right but we really don't
know does this demand for increasing
accountability
does it actually produce more
accountability could we impose it from
the outside or should it be more of an
organic felt accountability right we
don't know and especially when it comes
to social media the puzzle here if we
want to formalize this on the one hand
social media scrutiny could improve
accountability the examples I showed
right uh the me too in Hollywood
there is some evidence I just do
evidence on the other hand it could also
worsen accountability so could we think
of when and what conditions uh does this
lead to improved accountability outcomes
versus worse in accountability and how
does that in turn could impact us it
could sort of what implications does it
have for Designing organizational roles
policies but also the design of
technology so that's the focus so my
question more broad question on how do
social media scrutiny impact the
accountability of Frontline
professionals such as triage nurses
right and with what organizational
consequences that's the question
let me give a summary a whole view of my
arguments and then I'll talk about the
specific case uh sort of highlight under
what conditions that social media
scrutiny could actually worsen
accountability
so my argument essentially is there are
certain conditions where scrutiny could
improve accountability
and those are when the pockets of
private information that people
individually know in circles but data
still remain private right and when it
becomes when it is posted on social
media it just doesn't become public
knowledge it's not that there's some new
information revealed right think again
of the Harvey Weinstein case it's an
open secret in Hollywood about Harry
Winston it's not some new information
that social media and investigative
journalist but the minute when it was
when there was like social media
scrutiny around that then what happened
was people who already know the
information they wanted to disassociate
from Harvey Weinstein from people like
him right which in turn trigger this
whole set of internal processes that
improve accountability they were like a
lot more policies enacted Within These
production companies on you know under
what conditions uh we should sort of you
know escalate these issues and so forth
so the first mechanism that could lead
to improved accountability is when this
private information or let's call it
open Secrets become common knowledge and
common knowledge is a very specific kind
of term it is not this information
available widespread it means that
everybody knows that everybody else
knows that this person
is a problem right
so that because everybody knows that
everybody else also knows
therefore they try to disassociate at
least right or they try to at least
publicly signal that they ruined
something to you know address this yes
just to make sure I understand yeah uh
sure all right so just to make sure I
understand
in your example all of the women in
Hollywood yeah it was already in some
sense common knowledge that Harvey
Weinstein had like was doing this yeah
so is it
is it about that it was common knowledge
now to not just the people who are
harmed like what's the boundary that got
crossed yeah yeah so it was not just the
people who were harmed it was it's not
just the women who knew right the
brothers in the company who knew about
it uh but everybody thought only a few
of them knew and therefore they don't
need to take any public actions to
Signal what this answers but now it is
common knowledge
is essentially what it does is people
know that others know and they know that
others know that I also know this issue
and therefore I have to do something
that's the essence of common knowledge
and therefore the others too who are not
related to this for instance a lot of
producers who had prioritized with
Harvey Weinstein they actually try to
disassociate and do a lot of Visible
Changes in their own companies related
to sexual harassment and the policies
around so that's the mechanism for
pockets of private information Open
Secret becomes common knowledge and
because of that people try to insist
that's a translate question I think so
I'm trying to understand the difference
between an open in secret and common
knowledge is Open Secret we all everyone
who was impacted already knew but here
it's actually is it about the the set of
people who now know it could be an Open
Secret amongst the entire world now yeah
essentially that right it becomes the
act of some private information pockets
of private information becoming uh into
the public essentially means that I know
that not just a few people know many
others know and the many others know
that I also possibly know about this
issue so there is no Escape I have to
actually do something think of say I'm a
head of a production company right I
have to sort of now say I can't plead
ignorance so I think that is the
mechanism private knowledge becomes
common knowledge yeah so I think that's
the mechanism that could impact change
whereas uh the other when does it worsen
accountability
the cases when scrutiny could disrupt
the meaning of a phenomenon right or a
definition of a meaning of a phenomenon
think again the example I gave of the
triage nurses there are some definitions
on water serious medical emergency is
and who should be admitted who should be
sent to a different what right but when
people jump in say that my incident you
have to take it seriously it's a real
emergency and if others also kind of
pile on onto that then it actually
disrupts the definition on water medical
emergency is who should be sent to an ER
this is critical care versus some other
unit that in turn
questions accountability because the
triage nurses are exposed and therefore
they act very self-protective for them
it's rational to categorize most
incidents as emergencies send them of
course it's actually like really uh
constrains the system right a lot of
like resources that are logged in uh but
for them they are not exposed anymore to
social media right so that's the
mechanism essentially when some private
information becomes common knowledge
could potentially improve accountability
but when a similar incident when it
challenges the definitions and others
kind of pylon saying why are you not
considering this person's medical issue
as an emergency right there is no kind
of pushback against it therefore a
rational strategy for an individual is
to categorize most things as according
to this new definition that the people
are so that's the difference that's sort
of the argument and the broader kind of
theme I want to talk about as
scrutiny especially in the wake of
social media has become kind of
spectacle and spectacles are not not
necessarily bad right spectacles could
actually as I mentioned could produce
this common knowledge produce some
incidents that pockets of people knew it
becomes much more widespread but
scrutiny could also
disrupt like commonly accepted
definitions and commonly accepted
definition is not again not necessarily
bad right there are a lot of thought
that went on to Define what is a serious
medical emergency this is not and if
everybody is challenging it publicly
without the professionals there's no
recourse for them it actually challenges
so that's sort of the broader argument
and I'll like walk this through using
one case on what happened but actually
worsened accountability so that's going
to be that any questions on these two
and why this happened what are some of
the processes that drive this especially
on the second part so that's going to be
the rest of the talk any questions so
far on the two mechanisms
awesome all right so let me talk about
the context my context are Emergency
Management organizations these are 9-1-1
think of them as call centers they do
more than that so the job of these call
centers
they attend 911 calls if you dial 9-1-1
it's essentially a person a Frontline
worker call taker who takes the call who
has a set of questions and decides to
categorize whether your incident is a
serious 911 emergency if not so that's
the context I'm going to talk about just
an example uh most of these call takers
are women racialized minorities and this
is a specific strategic research site
for me to understand these questions
because
a lot of flick his shoes are on social
media scrutiny happens and you would be
surprised I'll show some examples people
complain people shout at these Court
takers saying why are you not sending a
cop my neighbor is throwing a party or
like you know my key my apartment key is
lost so they shout about it sometimes
they complain on social media and again
you'd be surprised on the kind of things
that goes viral uh the kind of
complaints the nature of those
complaints so that's why I thought okay
there's an opportunity for me to look at
how people's behavior change the call
takers Behavior change before and after
a particular incident goes viral a
particular instance of scrutiny so
that's the context
uh let me give some examples for social
media scrutiny largely on Twitter people
go to Twitter to complain so you could
read some uh the first one on my car got
broken into I call 911 to report this
women and she asked me to file this uh
to local police station again buy
protocol by the organizational policy if
the perpetrator is not on the scene
there is no purpose sending an officer
to the scene so the protocol is you go
to the nearest police station file a
report and they'll give you instructions
on that right but this person was
unhappy wrote about it the other
examples too loud construction going on
Senator police right send someone it's
again a 3-1-1 issue more administrative
issue when people get upset they
complain they have like a lot of
examples like that I will show so this
is the phenomenon I'm talking about
people dialing 9-1-1 getting absurd and
the Callback it says sorry I cannot send
cop or I cannot send an ambulance
because it's not a serious instrument
right so the reset setting uh let's call
it it's in a major city in the U.S they
get around 6 million calls let's call it
Delta City pseudonym and the
organization I study the main one is
better cities emergency management
organization or demo for short and their
Police Department too so that's my main
site I also traveled around to see how
prevalent this issue is is that only
within that particular center or is it a
much more common issue looks like it is
so but my focus for today's talk is
going to be mainly on the my main Side
Dental City uh the data sources as I
said mainly observations I sat next to a
call taker listen to the calls uh see
how they behaved how they categorize the
calls essentially before and after a
major social media incident and I'll
talk about them too I also had access to
ah they have call Locks so whenever you
dial 9-1-1 uh you there's essentially
every call gets recorded and you could
uh how the call taker categorized the
call whether it was a serious emergency
or not what kind of priority level they
assign all of them are like as a part of
that uh call log it's a repeated
cross-section data so I had access to
that too for multiple years to see how
the call taker's Behavior has changed
it's almost like a trace data you could
see you have it you're categorizing
differently or they're assigning more
priority level or not so that was an
important data source in addition I
actually scraped the Twitter feeds uh
when people actually they hashtag or
they add this particular organization or
demo so I was able to scrape those and
see essentially collect data around that
right so that's the data let me talk a
bit more about what this organization
does what do the call takers do so the
call takers as I said they are the front
line workers they collect the call they
they ask a series of questions if you
dial 9-1-1 to First determine what type
of incident is it right is it a police
Fire EMS incident and then to determine
is it really a 911 level emergency is it
that serious to because there are only
so many officers so many cops so many
ambulances so they decide that they have
a lot of discretion and determining
which call is an emergency which one is
not and then once they decide that okay
this call is a 9-1-1 level emergency
then they try to categorize it assign a
priority level and then send it to the
second sort of role in this process
these are the dispatchers the
dispatchers are the one who determine
who is the nearest first responder who's
the nearest co-oper EMT and they will
sort of send them and then basically
coordinate right so two important points
I want to note this process is when the
call takers have discretion right
although there are like protocols and
policies there are always some Gap to
determine what is an actual emergency so
they have discretion and determining
okay based on the information I
collected based on my training this call
is not an emergency they will tell that
to the caller too right the second kind
of point is this is a multi-stage
process at least there are you know
three year olds right the call takers
the dispatchers and the EMTs and the
First Responders so these two actually
play an important role too on some of
the things I'm going to describe so any
questions so far on you know the setting
or any any kind of yeah yes
clarify like we're looking at this graph
if you were calling and let's say your
emergency is a fire emergency would you
theoretically go through three different
people as you go to the police side call
taker the fire medical the Fireside call
taker through the fire dispatching it or
are some of those Invisibles yeah you
only talk to the first the front line
worker right that's why it's only to the
call call Taker and then depending on
what they decide then they can send it
out or not send it out
those beans and doubt would not be
transformed yeah exactly yeah awesome
great so I'm not going to go too much
into the data analysis but I want to
talk about my unit right what what did I
measure what are the things that I
observed to essentially see if things if
there's increased accountability or not
so the main thing I measured was how did
the call takers answer the calls there
are certain ways they answer the caller
right they will first let them talk make
sure that their Panic is reduced and
then ask questions
and then they determine how to
categorize the call right is it an
emergency or not what priority level so
that's my one main unit the other unit
was because of the actions of the call
takers the front line professionals how
did that impact the practices of other
people in the chain right police
officers the dispatchers do their
actions in response to social media
scrutiny actually make the world life
difficult for others right so that was
my second unit I'll show some evidence
on both of the East right so let me talk
about step back a bit and talk about
what does the call takers do right I
gave some general idea but there are
actually
specific guidelines and trainings on
what their role is what their mandate is
right so one of their important
mandators to answer the calls in a
empathetic tone engage matter because
the people who are calling I mean they
are probably facing the worst day of
their life at least according to them
right so you have to respect that you
have to sort of calm them down before
answer before asking a bunch of
questions so that's their first kind of
mandate treat the callers respectfully
and then the second is
you still have to do your job your job
is essentially a triage kind of role you
have to answer questions you have to
essentially categorize the call properly
so these are the two mandates and
sometimes they conflict us you could see
there could be people who could go on
and on and they might not give the
correct information or there might be
others who get really upset when the
call taker says sorry I cannot send a
co-op or an ambulance for you right so
as this person says this is sort of part
of their like manual they need to excel
at calming people who are frightened
Panic you're upset they also have to
solicit information from the callers to
accurately determine the gravity of the
instrument right so sometimes this
conflict so how do what are some of the
internal practices accountability
practices that this organization has to
make sure that the callers are doing the
job that they are accountable for their
actions so there are some practices the
most important one is called call
monitoring
so in the organization it'll be like
every ship that are six or seven
supervisors right whose job is to
secretly listen to the call takers every
month they have to listen to them twice
twice as essentially assess how are they
taking the call are they categorizing it
properly or not and then every month
they give feedback private feedback
we'll call take a step you did this well
you didn't do this well and there are
some consequences if they actually screw
up multiple times right so that's one
practice an important one to enforce
accountability internally
and it is not that this practice was
perfect right they were actually
sometimes their mistakes but by and
large this was effective in
communicating back to the colleague or
so on how they are doing what they need
to improve or not right so this private
feedback within the organization that
have been set up have been around for
years it's more or less do works right
now enter social media right uh Things
become a lot more complicated when
people can use social media to
scrutinize and this is especially sir
and there is increased noise and
information and by that what I mean is
now people the Advent of you know
smartphones mobile phones the kind of
calls that the these centers get have
also changed quite a bit what my
participants call it's not my term they
call as BS calls essentially also some
examples this is one during the covid-19
and they make the early early stages
people call to complain that run out of
toilet papers and they think that's a
legitimate emergency probably just for
them because there are many other many
other examples people call when the
refrigerator is not working or when the
kitchen sink is blocked and they think
that's an emergency that Demands a
response from the city and if the call
taker says no they get very angry they
get very upset about that right and I
mean these looks like funny examples but
the broader kind of undercurrent is
almost the lack or the collapse of
community at least in the U.S cities
right if my kitchen sink is blocked or
something happens I'd probably knocked
sort of my neighbor right ask for help
but there are a lot of people dependent
on the city or some kind of government
services right and it was fine to a
certain extent people would the call
takers would give some examples some
kind of help right and say that sorry we
cannot send an ambulance or paramedic
for its Australian emergency but now
again enter social media right now
people could actually name and shame
they're called takers sometimes all the
outgoing calls could be recorded and
they post portions of the call so forth
let me give one example to essentially
highlight this right so the blue is the
it's a call taker the red is the the
caller so the call taker said this 911
this is operator Morgan what is your
emergency they had to actually tell
their last name for accountability
reasons the caller says I don't know
what happened really but I think a beast
on my kid she's crying you said a beam
has a b and then she asked a bunch of
questions protocol questions on are
there any spellings or notice not that I
could see but she's still crying again
instead of questions are there any
allergies she developed no the mom
answers that no I don't see anything
then the call taker after asking those
questions says mom we cannot dispatch
for this please Supply some ice whether
we had stronger and keep it for a few
minutes the caller goes you said eyes
never is turned on yes ma'am few seconds
of Silence on the other end
saying I know to apply eyes I don't need
to call you people for it you know I
essentially want a paramedic or an EMT
on my desk and you're not sending it out
so she's very upset by that but she
didn't stop there at shrouding at the
collars right call the call she went to
social media
wrote it she wrote A Blog about this
incident and then she tweeted about this
tweet star and there she said oh my
six-year-old develop analogy when she
answered that no there was no allergy
right and she was very upset by this
whole incident and again from Mom's
perspective perhaps she thinks it's an
emergency and I'm not sort of
discounting that but from the
organizational perspective
they cannot dispatch an ambulance for
this there are only so many ambulances
right the interesting part here is you
would expect others coming in and
correcting this right the social media
users the Twitter users and I've looked
at the retweets or the comments some of
them yes they said no this is not an
emergency many others actually call
names essentially calling out the call
takers saying she's just a bureaucracy
paper pusher she doesn't care she's not
really worried about you know your kid
she's a waste of tax-based money and so
forth right so as you could see from the
perspective of the caller they have a
different kind of definition
expectations of what an emergency is
what a 911 level emergency is which kind
of doesn't match with the organizational
definitions right and because others
kind of also hold on to this incident it
creates this conundrum for the
organization what should they do now
should they sort of send this out or
should they kind of you know stop and
push back against the against the people
who complain and they tried that they
actually
uh started a Twitter account and tried
to respond to such incidents and what do
you think happened in those cases where
they tried to push back respond to
incidents such as the saying no this is
not really an emergency any guesses what
happened when the organization tried to
push back against this
they just make things worse exactly
right make things work people said oh
you're just gaslighting you're
obfuscating the whole thing you're not
doing your job properly and then you're
blaming us right so essentially that's
what again it's not that everybody did
that by and large a lot of people the
more the local people did this and this
created a problem for organization I can
show many such examples right where
people getting upset going to social
media and then you know complaining and
others kind of piling on to this right
so this is all like fine and so far as
the organization could say you're not
going to do anything about it right
we're just going to go about doing the
job but given again the the public
visible nature of such acts of scrutiny
what essentially happens is at some
point
the organization had to respond
publicly signal that they're doing
something about it so I'll sort of
explain what happened next couple of
slides where uh this particular graph
shows the x-axis is a week since a major
Scandal broke out right I'll talk about
what that Scandal was the y-axis the
average percentage of calls that are
categorized by the call takers by and
large as a valid 911 level emergency
right I've seen the data goes back
almost four years and as you could see
uh the average percentage kind of wavers
around 55 to 60 percent right that was
50 to 60 percent so if you get 100 calls
per year uh 50 of them are actually
categorized as emergency and that
Baseline You could argue is the right
baseline or not but based on again my
own observations listening to these
calls by and large they get this right
they're always on the side of caution so
even if they think that okay looks like
this might potentially become an
emergency they will still send out of
Officer or a cop or an ambulance right
so 55 60 percent is the Baseline and
then the orange dots you see these or
each one is like around 20 minor
incidents of social media scrutiny right
so that happened it happened for like
almost a year these minor incidents of
scrutiny right at one point there was a
major incident the Red Dot you see was a
major incident and I can't go too much
into the details of the incident but
essentially it was
there was a mistaken identity of a
perpetrator and a victim of her
emergency of an incident it was the
police officers of this particular
department they mistook who the victim
was and who the perpetrator was and that
led to a essentially a gunshot and the
victim was unfortunately was wounded
right and
was actually the police officer who was
on the scene who didn't actually listen
to the information provided by the call
takers and the dispatchers but
because
because like is the main one one
organization that got scandalized all
the orange dots you see who got Exposed
on social media a lot right the
organizations the 911 centers directors
they're they had to sort of visibly
signal something that they are doing to
essentially calm the Public's passions
right and the time the public where on
social media they were like you [ __ ]
screwed up you didn't collect enough
information but the call record showed
that the call taker asked information
about the victim the perpetrator
addressed the color of the dress she's
wearing right but it was not listened
properly by the police so a couple of
police officers got suspended but one
call taken on a dispatcher associated
with this incident too got suspended
despite there it's not their fault and
there was information to push back too
right so I hope like this uh sort of the
information is clear right the
organization the demo organization had
information on what kind of questions
the call takers has did they did their
job properly or not they categorized it
correctly or Not Right But despite all
of that despite the ability to push back
the director of the center decided that
they can't do it because if they push
back it's going to be a lot more Flack
and the City Hall was actually coming
hard on this organization so for them
the easy thing to do is a visible signal
that you're doing something we're taking
your concerns seriously and essentially
suspend a call taker under dispatcher
who associated with that incident right
so that was the major spark and then
after that you could see this big spike
right speak spike is essentially from
that incident of the suspension
or the the average percentage of calls
moved from around 52 percent to 78 right
almost quite a big jump it eventually
came down but it reached a new normal
around like 60 yes
did the number of calls remain roughly
the same or is there any kind of yeah
like suggestion when I unless I get a
cough that's great that's correct so the
cost uh or the last four year period
increase but not much after the Scandal
right it's called Sligo moralists remain
the same and I kind of talk about those
alternative explanations too right so is
it is it the suspension that triggered
this or not the social media incident
tough to say but there were other
suspension incidents this is a very much
a three strikes and out kind of
organization right if you scroll up
multiple times you will get suspended so
there were prior incidents of
suspensions and you don't see a similar
kind of Spike people are still trying to
do their job properly right there was
also a suspension related to a
mainstream media Scandal right there was
an investigative reporter who complained
about the center that people are doing
over time a lot and there too even
though it's not the fault of the people
who are doing overtime they're short
staffed the director of the center again
suspended a couple of people
right saying that oh we can't over time
you have to be like you're sort of
taking advantage of over time and
getting paid a lot more right so that
was this uh the circle you say a
mainstream Scandal and then a suspension
that followed that and here too you
don't see a huge Spike right so the
argument I'm trying to build is
it's not like
uh the unfairness of the bureaucracy
that made the quality curse behave
become very self-protective the spike
you see right you don't see a similar
Spike after that first suspension after
the mainstream this media Scandal so
they are in some sense developed
tolerance for bureaucratic you know
misbehavior right we could sort of all
kind of relate to it right we might be
upset with universities policies and we
almost have developed some kind of
tolerance for that we try to navigate it
but if the students of our clients
behave they sort of write nasty comments
on our you know student evaluations and
especially when they are public on sites
like great my professor then the kind of
the the relationship changed
relationship with our word changes and
in fact there are some studies showing
that the minutes clients like students
complain on public platforms like create
my professor the syllabus of the
professors or the following year becomes
a lot more diluted there is great
inflation after that so there's
something to do with the relation with
the client are supposed to just
bureaucratic punishment right of course
the bureaucracy plays a second order
role in this they could have protected
them right but they were unable to they
still chose suspension so that's the
argument I'm trying to build here it is
what does social media do in these
circumstances it allows the clients who
you interact with people who you think
you're trying to help as a Frontline
professional
it gives a sense that they are turned
against us right they become mean they
have turned against us and then they're
going on social media and complaining
without any attempt to understand the
nature of their hard work right or so
any questions on this
so has this particular call Tech
assessed nobody likes to do this
categorizing more incoming calls as
emergencies because they understand the
consequences right but nobody likes to
see either look at what day by day they
mean the public the clients writing
about us is just painful this is a
stressful job this is not a way to treat
us right so that's the first likewise
this particular call taker says you know
I don't feel like coming to work anymore
I feel no connection with any of this
people in this town are become so
entitled especially the ones on the
social media they don't want really want
answers they just want heads to roll
like those cheering bloodthirsty more on
Gladiator right very powerful code but
essentially again I was very puzzled by
this reaction of why are they so upset
with the clients as opposed to the the
bureaucracy the Senior Management who
were punishing them but my sense was
this was a lot more impactful emotional
for them right we signed into this job
to help the callers save their lives
essentially and we can tolerate any kind
of bureaucratic you know misbehavior or
bureaucratic punishments but if the
clients also are like behaving in a very
mean way and I'm just going to throw the
towel and do the stuff that makes me
protect that makes me very
self-protective right so that's the
first kind of thing that happened this
person too says hi sort of when I joined
demo I was warned that one should
develop a thick skin to survive in this
job callers can get mean and abusive I
can take that that I know they're having
a bad day that's part of their training
right you have to calm down the callers
but going to social media blaming us for
doing our job that is something else
next time I'll be more careful but I
said what they mean is not I'll
categorize the calls properly but that I
will just categorize everything as or
most things as a 9-1-1 emergency right
so that's the first then you might ask
okay what role does hierarchy place
especially the supervisors right as you
could as you might remember the role of
the supervise is to monitor secretly
give feedback to the call takers every
month so it's not that the call the
supervisors are blindsided by this
process they know what is going on as
the supervisor says you know I know what
is going on that's my job you know but I
don't feel like calling them out on this
uh by the semester call takers as their
boss I want to make sure that they are
safe and protected so I tell them all I
tell them is don't screw it up don't
jinx it because I care about them and I
don't want some Twitter troll to abuse
them right so their job essentially they
are saying I'm going to look the other
side you do whatever you want to avoid
the next candle even if it actually
impacts the organization right even if
kind of locks up resources and so forth
so that's the I don't know what happened
okay so that's the that's why the
hierarchy you would expect it to come
and correct things but it didn't this
time they just turned the other side
right and they didn't just stop there
right uh not just with the individuals
trying to play it safe being very
suspective it create a whole kind of
cascading consequence on others on the
dispatchers on the police officers too
so they are like you know I'm getting so
many calls these days I cannot handle
right so uh this particular politicus
says I have come to terms with this just
take the call get the info send it out
that's all there is to it have a try to
book a rebooking a flight and listen to
the Bland voice on the other side of the
line I am just that person now I'm sure
she will never get into trouble I'll be
her answer the callers the way she does
essentially saying I just whatever they
want I'm going to give them if they want
a cop I'm going to give that to them
right there is nothing more to it right
so this as I said creates this cascading
set of Consequence the work of the
dispatchers now the dispatchers have to
handle so many calls that are
categorized from 50 to person to 78 80
percent of calls right so they feel like
their relation with the callers are
straight and likewise the relation
between the dispatchers and the police
officers so they are the ones who
interact with the police officers right
that also got like really strange
officers felt I feel like a call Chaser
I say I'm getting sent on all these like
vs calls and I'm not supposed to be I'm
not in this giant sign and sign up for
this job to do this right so across the
chain there's this strained relation but
the big so what is essentially the
response time for even serious
emergencies have increased as you could
imagine if the BS calls the low-level
calls are categorized and you could only
dispatch on the order it comes so the
higher priority calls have to wait
longer ambulances or say think of a
cardiac arrest right you only have so
many ambulances at that point so the
higher priority emergencies there's
almost a 36 percent increase on that
year for the response time for higher
priorities emergencies and uh the more
even more broader consequences says that
and especially now but even at the time
there are a lot of initiatives to
rethink the function of the police
unbundle the functions of the police and
asking questions like should we even
send police officers to calls about
mental health issues or you know drug
abuse issues is that a job of a police
officer are they even capable of
handling that or should it be sent to
social workers or mental health workers
right now the conversation is even more
strong but if the public or at least
certain portions of the public demands
that they want and if the organization
like a demo allows that to be possible
it's very important to very difficult to
implement these broader initiatives you
cannot really unbundle or def on the
police given the kind of conflicting
pressures the public is facing on these
organizations so this particular
initiative there's some attempt to sort
of rethink the function of the police
they were not able to do it because the
officers are so overloaded they have
they always calls after calls so very
difficult for them to attend these right
so that's the broader consequence on
difficult to implement police change
initiatives police accountability
initiatives because of the demand from
the public right and more broadly
now what is the definition of 911
emergency is there a boundary could we
think of what is and what is not of
course there is an organization
definition right some criteria to
determine but now everything as this
person says a manager of this
organization I don't know what an
emergency is these days like seriously
what is it there used to be definition
what a 911 emergency is what is the 311
emergency but now everything is an
emergency to the people they want to be
service right away now it is like
they're calling for an Uber and they
want it right now Uber for everything
right again it's not all the public
right this portion of the public who are
doing this going to social media and
complaining but the perceptions it
creates is the public wants to be
serviced right now our hands are tired
essentially right so any questions so
far before I kind of talk about the the
broader yes so you had people that were
worried about what was being said about
them on on Twitter did you talk to
people that weren't using any of those
platforms and did you see a difference
in their perspective of it uh they're
called fakers
uh so uh many of them didn't have a
Twitter account it was actually the
organization after these repeated
scandals or repeated incidents uh the
city hall asked them to set up a unit to
monitor the Twitter feeds and if some
call taker is named the job of that
particular unit the social media
monitoring unit is to tell them that
this has happened just you better be
aware of it right so they've been
informed about it at some point they
stopped informing them but even if they
don't individually have an account or
monitor the new spreads right someone
else would say I got called out on
social media for no wrong of mine so
therefore together they sort of chat
about it during the breaks and the
collective Spike you saw was a result of
those kind of informal conversations
yes
yep
um what extent does organizational
action like the extreme cases of
suspending power workers to an extent
does that actually affect the Public's
impression did you mentioned that the
number of calls during graduation yeah
yeah
uh so the complaints on Twitter
especially after the say for the next
few days for bu for the next week has
like at least like calmed down a bit
right again started for a different
issue but that was the immediate
Consequence the number of times they got
hashtag they got called out that reduced
it's almost like I got what I want or
like almost you're taking my concern
seriously and therefore I will stop
complaining on so that happened on
Twitter essentially
other questions okay great so I'll sort
of summarize right I started with asking
when does social media scrutiny could
you know improve versus obscure or
worsen accountability and the improve
I've given some examples right me too
example this is a good example on when
social media scrutiny could worsen or
even obscure accountability when it
challenges publicly challenges
established definitions right and again
as I said sometimes it would be good to
challenge established definitions but
not always right there's some thought
behind defining what a 911 emergency is
depending on the resources the city had
depending on how many co-ops ambulances
now if everybody complains that there's
no channel to push back at least in the
current state of things it actually
leads to worse outcome so this is sort
of the model I talk about the swishiest
cycle right like public complaints on
social media and then at some point the
organization has to act publicly signal
that they are doing something they
cannot push back if they push back they
say you're just gaslighting us or you're
just obfuscating it right and the
pushback is the Easy Action for them is
suspending people or doing some punitive
action on the personal lowest power in
the organization in this case the call
taker right that's the easiest for them
to do and almost like they're forced to
do some sense structurally and that
creates this set of Downstream
consequences the call takers becoming
very risk-averse very self-protective
they are like I'm not going to do my job
properly because I'm getting exposed and
that creates Downstream consequences
more resources getting locked up and
even more broadly you're sending
officers unnecessarily to incidents that
they shouldn't be there and therefore
which has the potential to even escalate
right so why should an officer be there
for like a somebody playing loud music
right there are other ways to address
those concerns there are even other
mechanisms like administrative Services
311 is there all right but the public
wants more and that in turn creates this
vicious cycle where people are not even
sure what they are accountable for as
this person says what exactly am I
supposed to do how am I assessed are you
it used to be very clear to me on what
makes for a good call taker what's the
proper way to answer calls Collective
information on whether it's a real
emergency and politely rejects the one
that are not right now it is confusing
the supervisors used to give us clear
feedback what I did well what I didn't
do well what I should improve they
stopped doing that we are not sure what
is the right way to reward yeah right so
essentially run clear about what they're
accountable for what is the criteria the
hell accountable towards and when
they're held accountable and who they
are accountable for too right before the
supervisors and the organization at
large now they are unclear the call
takers are unclear so this is the last
slide so what are the broader takeaways
right social media scrutiny of low
powered workers just 911 call takers it
actually creates this glass cage for
them right they're constantly visible to
the outside world therefore they have to
almost like perform orchestrate the
practices in a certain way that they are
not exposed or at least they are not
like criticized in an unfair manner
again it's rational from their
perspective to do so but it produces all
these Downstream consequences right so
more and more broadly
scrutiny has a spectacle that social
media allows to do that right we create
these big spectacles and spectacles not
necessarily are bad me too in some sense
was a spectacle right a lot of issues a
lot of conversation the societal
discourse for the first few weeks was
around that and it created a positive
change because it disseminated this
pockets of private information to common
knowledge and therefore people who are
associated with uh like folks like
Harvey Weinstein they had to take some
public actions whereas in other cases
such as the example I gave uh scrutiny
has a spectacle could disrupt the
meaning and definition of a particular
phenomenon in this case it is what is
the meaning what is the boundary of
emergency right and given there is very
less revenue for people to push back the
organizations to push back these new
definitions become the gnaw right even
though there are not much resources the
city level to address those and that
creates this vicious cycle the
subsequent accountability people are
unclear that who they are accountable
for what what purposes and therefore
they're like some implications would
love your thoughts on you know the
current way we Design Technology such as
Twitter it is designed to create these
spectacles right so why is there retweet
button on the homes page of Twitter
right if you see a tweet you could
retweet it in an instance right even
though you don't even read it fully so
could there be could we think of
different ways to design those
Technologies maybe you should sort of
click on it and maybe there's a
threshold many people retweeted only
that it should be shared widely there
are other options rethink technology
design that doesn't create these wide
spectacles in an unfair Manner and for
organizations the the implication is
that
perhaps there should be some Avenues to
push back at least privately to take
down a particular post or to if someone
is named in shame in an unfair manner
the organizational managers should have
someone who needs to do that on the
social media platform should provide
those yes to push back right so but I
would love your thoughts on how this
could translate to technology design
where you know technology is designed
for more user engagement create these
you know unintendedly it creates these
spectacles which doesn't help some level
for people like denoin call takers so
what are other avenues we could think
about so that's sort of the open
question I have for you folks with that
thank you again thanks for your
[Applause]
all right we have a few minutes for
questions and
feedback
sure
um so thank you so much uh I sort of on
that subject of like technology design
and Twitter specifically yeah
um it seemed like in the example of the
B right yeah the person who posted on
Twitter yeah almost sort of was lying or
not being super
um you know transparent like she was
biased in the way that she reported what
happened she said you know things that
weren't necessarily true yeah about the
the interaction that they had and so I
know Twitter right now is testing
something where uh if you go to
um like retweet an article or a a meme
or something that's like yeah
took that back right now I think you
could retweet it even though you haven't
read it yeah yeah
um and I know they've uh recently
they've been testing labels on things
from community members so if you see
something that's fake there will be a
little label under it that says you know
for added context users have said this
isn't representative or something like
that God so I'm I'm just sort of uh my
thought was yeah
um because people are reporting these
incidents in ways that might not be
fully honest
um if maybe you think it it might help
uh to have Twitter in any interaction
with
you know police or a 9-1-1 dispatcher or
something like that for them to just put
a little label on it that says something
like you know remember this is just this
person's experience or remember yeah
yeah yeah take both sides into account
or something like that yeah I mean they
tried it not through labels but just
commenting on this but they're actually
backfired right the people were like no
no like you know we believe the account
of the people who according to the
Twitter users are the most low powered
but not necessarily the case objectively
right sometimes they are as you said not
not presenting the whole information
yeah but would love to know I mean what
kind of interventions one could do from
the design side to avoid these I mean
people talk about fake news but the how
to control fake news but this is not
fake news or maybe it is but there's
some kind of you know some kind of
threshold one should have to name and
shame someone or post videos or like
their voices right so what kind of
threshold what kind of mechanisms
all right
so you have these two criteria one is
where it's taking private knowledge and
turning into common knowledge that
improves and the other one is if it's
disrupting this definition and meaning
of the phenomenon which harms yeah
many situations are not Cut and Clear
one or the other yeah yeah and when
there's this and when they are engaging
both yeah does your theory have a
prediction about which of the outcomes
will dominate yeah yeah that's a great
question I mean that's something I've
been thinking about that could be
instances where things are like made
common knowledge which also challenges
the definition of the situation right I
don't have a strong prediction on what
would happen uh in those circumstances
my sense is if those definitions
actually are an improvement over what
existed before perhaps that's that's a
good thing right say you know maybe in
the medical emergency case they have
like under categorized certain incidents
as not serious emergencies and if people
push back and say no no you should
consider them these incidents to ask a
serious emergency and perhaps it's good
but by and large what I find is is
people's own Impressions about almost an
entitled impression on I need help or I
just whatever about my definition of the
situation is that's what you should
accept that without any challenge then
it actually worsens things right
um do you know it sure do you know if
there's any scholarship that's looked at
the
interactions between users and Frontline
workers in retail around masking
requirements and interesting Industries
yeah there are some work I don't think
it was very expensive but there's some
interview based studies on how do the
retail workers reacted when someone
walked in without a mask and they tried
to push back and uh it's typically like
you know they get shouted out but it's
actually the in those circumstances it's
the workers who take videos of those
people who don't wear a mask right uh so
not not the other way around but there's
some work I'm happy to share
foreign
thank you